what's wrong with cardinals well okay
they're not that talented that's the
first thing to talk about their defense
certainly like nothing special on that
side of the football okay so you know
when you think of the cardinals who are
you thinking about on defense as being a
difference maker right right now the
only guy is chandler jones who's really
like a top level player they got some
nice young talent and some guys who you
think okay they're gonna they could be
good a few years down the road
offensively i'll say kind of the same
thing mike i mean hey you know who's
there really to be scared of on that
offense you know fitzgerald is solid
he's good but he's not a superstar
anymore we know that i mean christian
kirk good but i'm not a superstar added
to the fact that
it's just
offensively and i've watched every game
on film to this point
you know
it's just nothing special mike there's
just it's not like football has gone oh
my gosh shotgun you mean offense we've
never seen before right that's gonna
work because we've never seen it before
i i'm still waiting to see what i
haven't seen before uh and and i think
yeah they're a little limited that way
they don't run the ball that well um
kyla murray is still young and trying to
figure out his way a little bit and make
some plays don't get me wrong without a
no talent no no huge talent around him
and then an offensive play caller who
yeah i don't think his depth of
inventory is that great to begin with
and he's still finding his way along uh
you know pycong in the nfl too we both
had seattle in our best bets last week
how did you do on yours i don't think i
think i went one in two i was two in one
damn i trusted so now we're gonna be
tied we're gonna be tied yeah you're
gonna you're ultimately gonna lose to me
just accept it here's the thing that
kyle murray has to accept yeah and and
this was a point peter king made before
the draft and some people gave him a
hard time for it i thought it's a very a
very appropriate point yeah kyler murray
has had tremendous success every level
of football right unquestioned right
never faced adversity here he is oh
three and one yeah how do you deal with
that right and and how does the team
deal with it and where does the team go
from here yeah and i had somebody point
out to me a couple of weeks ago kind of
ingest that two or three years from now
the gm will be fired the coach will be
fired and kyler murray will be playing
baseball
who knows who knows i i mean i i don't
think that'll happen i will say this
watching the game yesterday i thought i
saw the first time of a little bit of
frustration from kyle murray on some
first and second down plays where you
know he was kind of like you know the
play was over and he was like like
you know making facial expressions and
like what the hell is going on here can
i get some pass protection or is anybody
ever going to get open i mean i did see
a little just a little you know
crack in the the armor there i thought
lincoln riley said that the big 12
defenses don't stink oh come on we know
that all right i mean like listen yeah i
mean the big 12 defense is stink and he
you know lincoln i got respect for what
he's doing but we know they stink okay
just look at the nfl draft look at
what's going on there right now jalen
hurts goes to oklahoma he couldn't
complete passes in the sec and now he's
going to oklahoma we're going is he
going to be the heisman winner i mean
that just shows you yeah he's on the
most talented team in oklahoma one of
the more talented teams in all college
football who's clearly the best team in
the big 12. that's not even close and
yes the the rest of the conference is
just not that talented or that good on
the defensive side of the ball all right
i don't know how much longer will we
talk about the cardinals this season if
they continue to follow that's excited
about kyle murray yeah but uh it's tough
especially in that division yeah where
the 49ers are three and oh
and the rams and seahawks are each three
and one and they play on thursday night
all right that's it we will see you
tomorrow for another edition of pft live
and p-f-t-o-t and everything else we
have going on you gotta unbutton today
yep you know it two games are breaking
down early results are chiefs lions i'll
be breaking down
and what was my other one i can't
remember oh my gosh i'm choking on the
spot i leave this dallas new orleans one
of these years i'm going to mobilize my
fan base to stuff the ballot box for
just a complete and total crap game oh i
have to break down thank you like coming
like like arizona seattle
it'll be jets dolphins for the first
time they get to be great
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports